au lendemain de de la présidentielle il
bien montré il me semble que il n'y a
ce que je suis
personnalités plutôt que deux projets je
dernier sondage qui a été réalisé
sais pas on pourrait en trouver encore
il parlait chacun une langue différente
info biz sur législatives et 10 et moi
mises en scène à l'américaine pour
stratégie électorale entre entre les uns
élites c'est évidemment le cas puisqu'il
faudrait évidemment la nuancer cette
vraiment monté en défense il faut voir
dans l'est dans les débats qui est le
et il n'a pas réussi à construire cet
de france 2 à la plateforme enregistre
autour des fractures françaises cette
droite et sa gauche etc mais quand vous
dans l'est dans les zones denses et
les français moyens j'allais dire devant
législatives est-ce que vous avez été
majax peut-être la phrase sur la
plusieurs comme ça et donc elle est dans
démocrates y voilà l'un des thèmes que
à la politique et ne pas avoir envie de
faire handicap discrimination habitat
sociale parce que si nous serons alors
carte on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure avec
match nul pour 33% des des français
pas de tentation disons islamophobe et
pense et c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
terrain au lendemain du débat
fait il il a mené une campagne en disant
livre vous vous montrez finalement
ya cinq ans ce finalement devenir le
et ils se rencontraient très rarement et
aujourd'hui
pour le peuple et le populisme c'est
chaîne d'info en continu je ne parle pas
des personnes qui étaient de gauche de
les cinq ans par une commission où tous
pourquoi les sens sur les populismes rou
la mise en scène médiatique c'était
surpris comme moi laetitia ce renard là
terminologie est ce qu'elles sont
avez la moitié en gros des catégories
je n'aime pas aller demandez l'aide
autres de force mais il ya ceux il
leur télévision c'est pas assez par un
le résultat vous disiez et évoluons dans
une stratégie en fait qui voit là est
et les autres voilà et moi j'ai eu pas
regarder le débat parce qu'on a déjà
ancrage local dont vous parlez en tout
vote marine le pen enfin ce qu'il crée
l'on va aborder tout de suite avec mes
premier ministre cette espèce de jeu
après le débat pour tenir compte de
une moyenne de 173 milles spectateurs
qu'il fallait cesser la
pas un hasard si on retient sa
premier repose en deux des manuels macro
présidentiel
peut-être vous l'avez évoqué dans la
mal de retours de gens sur le terrain
jour lui dit ça de dire ça c'est que ce
bat pas si correspond assez bien à la
indigne une colère sociale ou point de
limite n'excite à sion comme ça mais
ravivées par la présidentielle ce sera
de public sénat bien sûr et c'est vrai
professionnalisation de la politique
les partis sont représentés et on laisse
les grandes villes c'est on à jean luc
relation de marine le pen avec
centre gauche et qui ont participé ce
on part un peu de jean luc mélenchon par
fait son choix
les différentes france kung fu
la députée d'extrême droite revient à
bruns emmanuel macron je ne sais pas si
d'hier c'est que ce match là on l'a dit
pont par dessus le second tour de la
qui sont proches de la france insoumise
surtout le symptôme d'une démocratie
invités laetitia strange bonnart bonsoir
tout à fait habituelle qui a l'air de
moyennes qui se tourner vers le vote
réunis sur les 4 chaînes avec un pic
l'impact du débat sur les intentions de
xénophobe celle et gilet jaune qui a
mise à distance des corps intermédiaires
l'annuaire poutine vous parlez à votre
cas si on en croit les résultats oui
sont des débats chi chi chi l'ha n'était
peut-être que le débat s'adresse aussi à
évidemment le thème central de notre
première partie de notre émission mais
emmanuel macron tente de donner des
le l'air dans laquelle marine le pen
mélenchon qui arrive en tête dans de
phénomène de vote utile alors que là
les on laisse les équipes de campagne en
cette sortie de du candidat de la france
parfois le désespoir on est deux qu'est
qu'on a mais c'est vrai que ce sont les
définition que vous donnez on
populiste c'est qu'il ya un gros
mettrait refaire mais aussi parce qu'il
présidentielle comme si au final mans ça
plutôt s'il ya un nationalisme il est
j'ai envie de vous faire commenté savent
confrontés à la mondialisation à
qui justement comment ça se sont
comme je le disais en introduction
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes essayiste
vous avez raison et puis je pense qu'on
l'un de ses thèmes de prédilection le
gages à l'électorat de gauche en se
était la plus à l'aise c'est les
il faut le rappeler le les camps de
banquier c'est ça alors je veux retenir
on l'a jouée il ya cinq ans on sait
pas pensé pour pour l'affrontement de
il l'a fait en mettant les syndicats un
quand on est en seine saint denis c'est
nombreuses grandes villes de france
dehors de ça on laisse les candidats en
vote une légère progression des manuels
on sait qu'aujourd'hui les lieux étaient
discussion jean-laurent cassely et c'est
problème c'est pas juste le vote des
c'est vrai qu'on garde du temps pour
ceux et bien qu'ils comptent s'abstenir
d'audience à 280 milles vers 22 heures
l'instant c'est intéressant le
peut donner un élément supplémentaire
n'avait aucune importance mais c'est une
y avait pas eu avant d'avant oui alors
fonctionner en ce moment parce qu'il ya
ce n'est pas la faute de marine le pen
peut en faire une description sans que
plutôt économique mais il n'est pas
l'impact de la position une fois d'une
rédactrice en chef à l'express vous
plutôt un électorat qui est plutôt de
inquiétés un peu voilà pour la suite de
communes peu denses les petites communes
petit peu à distance et personnalisation
pour analyser les fractures de notre
dehors de ça et on rappelle que dans le
présentant comme le défenseur des
deux projets qui étaient plutôt
saucissonnage renforce est cette
recours aux travailleurs détachés
losers des excuses c'est le vote est
irréconciliables avec ces zones
qui est que la france a soumises a tenté
la france qui ne se sent pas ou plus
identitaire et il me semble ça c'est
qu'il ya deux france on connaît cette
tiens d'ailleurs jean-laurent cassely
publiez de la france ce pays que l'on
macron qui est à
un problème justement avec nos
oui et puis marine le pen avait refusé
les communes rurales mais aussi quand on
france d'ailleurs qu'on ne connaît pas
chaque candidat qui fournissent les
du pouvoir on l'a vu plusieurs fois est
c'est le symptôme de nos systèmes qui
vous avez le droit de dire que je vous
classes populaires et qu'il a réussi à
quartiers populaires l'ensemble des
stratégie 20e que peut-il dire d'autre
quelqu'un qui jouait offensive ce stade
évidemment il ya ce qu'on peut appeler
l'abandon de la france périphérique farl
ce soit un jugement de valeur bien sûr
moderne existe bien
opposition j'ai l'impression
justement périphériques bas comme s'il
gelée vu en allant danser dans ces
modèle américain les candidats à la
57,5 % d'intentions de vote contre 40 2
société mais plutôt vainqueur du débat
et donc parmi ces personnes certaines
a deux cantons des communes rurales ça
tout débat bien sûr que manuel macumba
sensation oui bien sûr mais vous avez
villages des meetings exactions meyrals
en retenez aucune c'est que c'est la
bien parce qu'on est encore dans un
ce que ça veut dire pour autant qu
ça devient un jugement de valeur parce
concernés par la politique elle grandit
de par certains aspects de se lancer
le méta débat c'est à dire que le débat
par leurs mouvements de disons que du
est ce que cette fracture cette vieille
qu'aujourd'hui on est plus dans la
important parce qu'on a essayé de
sont vieillis qui sont usés et pour que
habitants de nos quartiers populaires
institutions et on en parlait tout à
veut dire qu'à que les agriculteurs il
mobiliser à travers bas en
ça me semble pas complètement absurde de
croyait connaître c'est aux éditions
emmanuel macron est un populiste ou une
phrase qui a été retenue par beaucoup de
fameux meeting c'est des gens normaux
fantasme de la france des trente
qu'après on considère que la démocratie
sur sa stature de chef d'état est une
allez je vous laisse dira mot là dessus
rapprocher les gels et jaune assez
tout à fait raison l'impression que j'ai
fallait choisir en fait dans la
séduction de pas forcément du troisième
il a été commentée sur les réseaux
ya aussi beaucoup d'employés d'ouvriers
l'heure le parlement la démocratie et de
sont une chance pour notre république on
fracture sociologique ville campagne est
ont peut être regardée par hasard mais
dire moi je qu'il pense déjà à la suite
inexorablement
médias moi je retiens plutôt des
perrin etienne lyon soir soir est
dans la course à cet électorat la france
important mais quand vous êtes présent
pen a refusé tout débat jusqu'à celui
seine-saint-denis justement toute une
souvent de justement d'une forme de
sorte je ne sais pas mais en tout cas je
le populisme disparaissent il faut que
c'est plutôt la complexité et la
sociaux et pourtant sa diffusion il a
glorieuses c'est assez intéressant jean
candidate qui elle voulait pas faire de
de petits fonctionnaires etc qui réside
eu vraiment à la fin de ceux de ce débat
d'une france moyenne voilà un extrait de
est ce que vous l'avez ressenti vous
à face avant l'élection merci marion
en tant qu'être humain dans un meeting
ennemis pour marine le pen ce qui fait
série d'actions qui ont été menées par
ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle se creuse à
ce point de vue là en effet il est
je crois pas que le débat soit vraiment
expressions des visages retient le
crois que ça amène à se poser la
est soumise a été présente assez
bloc est de la france du milieu en fait
délibération donc c'est vrai que le
comme téléspectateurs oui parce que
les mots m a eu x de notre démocratie
et d'ailleurs c'est plus généralement on
d'hier donc israël accepter un débat à
je ne saurais dire je moi j'ai pendant
suscité 1,7 million de tweets et 2 5
luc mélenchon c'est celui qui propose
rejet identitaire alors bien sûr il ya
c'est qu'il s'adressait à 2 france
a beaucoup ces derniers mois
vous c'est en fait c'est pas très
peut-être temps de dust est d'agir de la
un écart de 15 points et car évidemment
sociologue chercheur au cnrs votre livre
décisif après ça ne signifie pas qu'on
question oublié dès le dernier chapitre
donc une france populaire et ça c'est
populisme et la démocratie ou part dans
voilà on sait que les cadres vont se
bourdes et ne pas marquer contre son
l'aune à l'aune du résultat de cette de
le parti pour être très présent via la
rapidement pas au début mais assez
visage des manuels mâcon
charnelle et on sent que c'est fait pour
jean-laurent cassely un débat
ce meeting vous étiez avignon 14 14
toujours des éléments i nouri terre dans
comme là on parle des segments
12 avec emmanuel mac d'accord en tout
probablement pas pousser les de l'état
stigmatiser ses habitants en réduisant
camp mais du coup on s'est ennuyé
complètement différent et le public
sans doute le virage économique où le
du populisme qui est justement la
disparaissent également les mots ce sont
reconnaître dans la dans la ffh tivement
rapidement dans les manifestations gilet
la candidat du rassemblement national
quand même un schéma convoi qui est pas
peut aussi penser les choses comme ça si
le populisme la démocratie n'ont pas
présidentiel c'est quand même un moment
électoraux peut-être qu'il faut pas
cette campagne j'ai été un peu au
vie associative via des comités de
cette élection et d'une mère plus
part d' emmanuel macron s'il est réélu
important c'est le plus important est
les candidats novices et professionnels
millions sur les dernières 24 heures et
pendant ce match ouais ouais mais mais
ne doivent pas en attendre quelque chose
complètement différent et que leur leur
les pour les télés pour les images des
les mouvements qui peuvent avoir ce
confiscation du pouvoir et est moins de
jaune et donc de ce point de vue là on
cas actuellement elle a refusé tous les
comme ça très fixe syrien fixement
forcément bien ensemble mais j'aurais
diapason des français c'est à dire que
oublier celui des plus de 65 ans qui a
la défiance envers le politique les
de mémoire collective vous voyez ce que
générale losc alors on voit bien pas
avril dernier marine le pen donc qui
on est attaché au parlement qui à mon
major a continué dans cette stratégie là
des jeunes dans un restaurant routier
les débats en opposant parfum en clivant
d'un débat et en l'occurrence je pense
qu'un relevé par ipsos depuis le
pour que la fatigue démocratique ne
modèle économique le plus radicalement
débats et donc il y avait comme ça cette
peut pas dire qu'ils n'ont pas essayé
systématique mais qui ressort quand
je les ai suivis en pointillés tout en
laëtitia soit je meurs je suis pas tout
la brillance de macron que les
juste aimé faire une petite distinction
enfin dernière information ce débat est
quartier et qui au jour de l'élection
jt est en fait la ferveur franchement
marinade dans les premières minutes et
mais le résultat des comptes et que
inégalités sociales qui sont exacerbées
liberté et muse
voilà on verra avec quel succès aux
leur verbatim leur leurs théories leur
fortement de ce premier tour et je
à fait d'accord avec vous sur le côté
avec des chauffeurs poids lourds et se
en politique aux presses universitaires
devienne pas une colère démocratique et
attente mary kate qui était qui est
renouvelée est ce que vous êtes d'accord
en fait la colère vis-à-vis des élites
oppose le bloc populaire et le bloc
dans cette carte justement mais dans le
gilet jaune c'est essentiellement au
avis n'a pas un rôle assez fort
faisant autre chose et je suis par
aujourd'hui disponible en replay sur
voté très majoritairement pour emmanuel
finalement ont payé et qui pourrait
que ce débat était quand même un petit
techno pas chez marine le pen et je
en plus il a une gestuelle un peu
je veux dire de qui participent à notre
catégories populaires sont sont plus à
aussi dans des chais des leaders qui ne
législatives sais c'est un peu la france
dirais que pour boucler avec la question
notre société en seine saint denis seuls
avec ça oui la question pour moi c'est
lendemain du premier tour de la
moi je les trouvais dans l'es2 quand
de france jean-laurent cassely bonsoir
résultat du premier tour que il ya trois
n'ont pas réussi j'ai une question un
mouvement social et économique qui
aujourd'hui eh bien on peut réfléchir à
fait le porte étendard de cette france
par kwh à part ça parce qu'on a
peu décevants notamment parce qu'il
youtube et notamment sur notre chaîne
que la table soit renversé sur lui on va
invasif son visage mais là où ce gratte
macron au premier tour qui va à nouveau
argumentaire était vraiment sur des
j'ai dû trouver et qu'elle n'était pas
élite est en écoute rendez vous du 24
du populisme je vais pas rajouter une
présidentielle et puis autre élément
à notre bien commun et est-ce que je
l'aise avec le l'empathie de marine le
vit et jaune etienne lyon dont on est en
payer dans la perspective des
peu tabou est-ce que la colonne
trouve que même dans les termes employés
exemple aller dans les meetings des
blocs qui s'affrontent vous avez un duo
victime selon elle du mépris affiché par
parlait très peu l'identité au sens au
sous les critiques ne sont pas toujours
sont pas populiste et donc ça ne peut
l'impression que tout se vaut et que moi
youtube ainsi le débat et les missions
très palpable et ni dans les discours ni
lignes parallèles qui ne pouvaient pas
définition mais moi ce qui m'intéresse
plutôt pourquoi dans ce cas là il n'est
la façon de construire une opposition
candidats notamment le grand meeting
déçu c'est comme un rendez vous amoureux
pas être une condition essentielle en
l'oreille il met les marques comme ça
elle faisait bien attention de ceux
20% des électeurs ont voté manuel magro
vous êtes journaliste pour slate pour
était très je trouve très technocratique
train de parler la france de la france
intéressant la question a été posée aux
avril vous l'avez compris mesdames et
pen et finalement je me demande si ce
vertébrale de cette france dit gilet
je vous vos thomas or non ce n'est pas
c'est c'est le fait quand on arrive à
reviens moi je suis un peu obsédé par
terminer là dessus merci effectivement
non justifié et je pense que dans le
voter pour lui au second et qui sont des
pas deuxième tour oui à 400 mille voix à
se rencontrer c'est à dire que l'a
intéressante au parlement alors pour
périphérique équipe qui a finalement
emmanuel macron au débat de la veille
pleine de ce populisme
de débris ce que vous animez hier thomas
vous voyez quand on vous dit que le
cette mauvaise audience je veux pas non
c'est à dire que ça permet du coup
pas moi je retiens une sorte de fouillis
l'express également essayé ce co auteur
sens ethnique et qui parlait plutôt de
42% pour marine le pen si on prend le
d'emmanuel maquereau à la défense arena
premier tour loin derrière jean-luc
messieurs met face à face le bloc
s'adresser à tous les français et d'être
ce sera l'un des défis des mains de
que ce qu'on n'essaie pas ce qu'ils
vrai et il y à aussi bien sur cette
finalement c'est moi je pense qu'il faut
paul macron mélenchon sur les grandes
français par par ipsos qui avez vous
j'ai eu face à moi un emmanuel macron
prince charmant arrivé que finalement
plus sur dimensionner les leçons qu'on
420 milles bois bref oui mais moi je
gens qui peuvent avoir peur en fait de
dans le dans l'est dans la fosse
a été vu par près de 200000 spectateurs
attaquée sur le fond sur la technicité
jaune n'est pas justement le
politique de société et d'économie et
logique avec la candidate du pouvoir
populisme il ya un mélange enfin en tout
sondage qui est qui lui est donc que
comme ça constant marine le pen comme ça
alors ce mouvement qui était tellement
avec jérôme fourquet de la france sous
certains ce serait celle de la gauche de
celui qui a fait à marseille et le
n'ont pas essayé de vers dans ce débat
mélenchon avec 49% des bois
peut en tirer mais est-ce que c'est pas
vous avez le voisin d'à côté bah ya
nationalisme n'est pas justement le
mâcon s'il est réélu et on va rester
plus défavorable celui d'aujourd'hui
s'est trouvé la bannière de séduire
composites sans aucun leader enfin va
populaire contre le bloc élitaire le
on voit donc qu'il ya une pluralité de
cas dans les danses que les gens
être attentif avec ces notions et à les
question quand même identitaire tous ces
meeting de marine le pen à avignon sud
l'instabilité
trouvé le plus convaincant et là c'était
contre emploi total je pense qu'elle a
égal à lui même
villes le cas de paris est emblématique
vois beaucoup depuis hier sur les
d'achat celle qui est ressentie par les
nos yeux économie paysages nouveaux
et elle en populiste qu'elle est
jean-luc mélenchon pour d'autres ça
là aussi un signe de cette france
alors je je je une petite digression
vous avez j'ai regardé dans la
du de l'arrivée de marine le pen à au
expriment il ya des critiques qui me
prudent malgré ces sondages qui nous
mais alors vas-y particulièrement de
utiliser avec vous avez aimé en fait
un petit peu crispé ça dit beaucoup à la
toujours de la déception c'est pareil
réseaux sociaux beaucoup de gens se
refus des minorités je le dis de façon
très méprisant très arrogant
dans l'entre-deux tours et j'étais assez
tout l'ouest et en orange ils votent
pas refaire l'histoire dès gilet jaune
problématiques identitaires qui renforce
modes de vie publié au seuil et lætitia
essayé de nylon se renforcer renforcer
cette france moyenne du milieu qui
ventilation en fait d'aider des
morcelée que les uns et les autres vous
emmanuel macron qui l'emportent 43% des
etienne au lion est ce que à l'aune de
support pour diffuser ce débat et
pourrait être aussi la droite parce que
utilisent des concepts complètement
pouvoir donc c'est plus pour des raisons
semble illégitime et notamment quand
ferveur de la part des militants qui se
bloc de ceux attachés à la sécurité
français comme ayant le plus de
donne un écart qui progresse entre un
un peu abrupte 1 est aussi incertain une
finalement vous vous rapprochez des
le populisme donc c'est finalement un un
mais est-ce qu'il n'a pas fini quand
mais ça montre aussi qu'on a énormément
frappé de voir que dans le public ton de
je dirais peut-être politico-économique
hésite entre les deux et ça on y
plaindre que le débat aurait été
en vous observé depuis depuis un certain
populations qui votent pour qu'ils ont
gestuelle et d'ailleurs même au début on
proximité avec beaucoup d' avance
macron tout l'est plus bobo et populaire
valises de comme celle d'emmanuel todd
clichés un peu vaporeux qui nous parle
c2c de ses audiences on peut craindre
de loin impression que les républicains
déplacent encore pour voir un meeting
personnes interrogées ont trouvé manuel
toucher des publics très différents mais
sociale contre le bloc dessus attaché au
cuba et guitariste politiques à rester à
reviendra dans un court instant est ce
elles expriment simplement de l'envy
parler d'identité nationale cet automne
même petit à petit par ce extrême
cet aspect là qui lui avait manqué il ya
beaucoup plus intéressant avec jean luc
que même morale qu'il a peut-être joué
il est dans la france mélenchonistes à
qui me semble admis ce genre de choses
temps on se construit de moins en moins
une intention de vote pour un tel ou tel
voilà deux points de vue là j'étais un
une abstention record dimanche est ce
militants quand même dû des premiers
votre mélenchon voilà si je résume les
macron le plus convaincant 24% marine le
poisson qui se mord la queue pour
d'ailleurs sur ce sur cette question sur
qu'il ya c'est assez compliqué on est à
mes côtés peut-être une réaction après
cinq ans donc là il connaissait bien ses
néanmoins si on additionne toutes les
parce que c'est le registre de l'émotion
sociale par exemple quand on dit on
macron n'était pas vraiment là parce que
certaine islamophobie bah moi je peux
on pensait on nous disait que c'était un
droitisée disons que la france
peu déçu alors on va continuer de deux
peu jour après jour voilà on est
mélenchon il fallait il fallait les les
saint denis un saint denis premier tour
autre ce qui est intéressant c'est
que il faut forcément faire le lien
ce rôle du chef de l'état rassurant
est en marche c'est la même chose mais
moins de 24 heures du débat mais est ce
de deux biens communs ou de souvenirs
mais qui ne peut pas rencontrer les
n'aime pas les riches on veut qu'ils
aussi sur emmanuel macron ça ne se dit
sujets elle regardait un petit peu ces
stopper le populisme il faut que ces
je crois aucun français qui eux même
les couronnes pauvres les banlieues
emmanuel macron oui alors je résume l
serre puisque c'était quelques dizaines
grand sujet l'immigration également en
pouvoir de l'argent le bloc dessus
audiences on attend toujours pas ce
maintenant à selon l'institut ipsos à
soient moins riches même si nous on
ils se déplaçaient un peu il était pas
encore une fois c'est pas que les
faits qualifiés qui passe et pour
qu'il ya une phrase que qu'on retiendra
périphérique déjà elle même elle est
pen et 33% ni l'un ni l'autre voilà
fiches mais bon franchement elle était
probablement pas en effet parce que
vous répondre je me permets juste ce que
notre reportage pour pour commencer on
de près il ya quand même des différences
collectifs est ce que vous êtes d'accord
quelques milliers de personnes puissent
n'est pas plus riche ça c'est de la vie
ouvriers votent le pen et des cas de
quelque assure couac est aux manettes et
jean luc mélenchon 61% mails macron 16%
d'ausculter en quelque sorte ses
record de 1981 mais même très loin même
j'ai vu les cet après midi des collègues
plus solide le problème c'est qu'il n'y
entre un public en marche et et la
arguments du technocrate sont deux
fait on ne s'est rendu compte à la fin
extrêmement composite est encore plus
mots soient résolus c'est pour ça que là
avec cette analyse avec cette idée c'est
droit et puis s'est mis petit à petit
impression générale on est dans cette
rebondir sur la question des
pas qu'on les met sur le même plan non
exactement ben en fait c'était pas plein
sociale et franchement ça a rien de bon
pour l'histoire une séquence je crois
patrons ça ça fait cinq ans maintenant
attaché au service public contre le bloc
populaires qui votent on la dit très
comme les tice il expliqué laëtitia
audiences records à la baisse avec
législatives
qui présentait sur un travail en cours
quinze points d'écart entre les deux
je veux dire j'ai entendu plusieurs fois
qu'on sait ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ne l'étaient les gilet jaune donc de
pendant cette campagne on en avait deux
ça n'aide personne mais en revanche si
avait aucun débat de fond est d'ailleurs
dans le dans le débat est en fait c'est
mais ça signifie que c'est une approche
strauss bonnart ya en effet un décalage
vrai que c'est un débat qu'on va quand
je pense que l'élève la vie dit il ya
ville qui n'ont pas regardé le débat
marine le pen mais pour cent alors en
visions très opposé la france etienne
aucun des deux candidats n'a fait salle
trailer effectivement aussi la question
cinq ans le président candidat arrive
marion vigreux qui doit être juste là en
technicité elle a en effet essayé à
comme par hasard le sujet c'était le
pas après l'histoire dira et puis on
ce point de vue là si on regarde ça avec
après le premier tour des jeunes dire on
même très vite oublié parce que comme je
sur les gilet jaune toi c'est un
massivement pour pour jean luc mélenchon
droite libérale conservatrice il ya
on allait eric zemmour et marine le pen
emmanuel macron à mon avis a choisi une
que la catégorie du milieu c'est-à-dire
de ceux qui vendent des fleurons de
de la politique qui se veut très direct
finalistes ça fait beaucoup merci je
au moment de la russie que ça a vraiment
entre les gens qui vont voter les gens
qui se pose désormais ce devons nous
pouvoir d'achat à mon avis on savait
relie aussi l'histoire ou à l'aune du
comme la grande majorité des électeurs
les données de l'insee on voit assez
nous a volé l'élection parce qu'il ya 40
coulisses voilà varions rebond soir
vous exprimer un manque de
effet l'argent lui qu'elles ont fait des
vous l'avais bien dit en fait on l'a on
lui en début d'après midi à saint denis
séminaire de recherche c'est des choses
et ça ce qui est intéressant c'est que
certains moment de prendre de la hauteur
lyon est ce que marine le pen a réussi
stratégie assez prudente qui était de
qui regardent le débat enfin quand même
notre industrie le bloc de ceux qui
les professions intermédiaires donc les
aussi une forme d'opposition qu'on peut
clairement que c'est assez assez
revoir le modèle de cet exercice qui
décollé sans mettre d'accord est ce
qui sont pas encore publiés on a notre
reconnaissance si vous avez l'impression
je le rappelle un 30 32 millions sur les
scores absolument incroyable dans ce
aussi un mec qui le peuple et qui peut
rappelle le titre de vos livres
gens agiter des petits drapeaux dans ses
est pas jean-luc mélenchon pour vous
où l'attend une masse de partisans pour
déjà et on n'a pas vraiment voulu voir
et d'ailleurs à ce moment là il change
c'est un schéma qui se reproduit dans
présent souvent et donc il est tout à
assure jouer la tente en fait on a
infirmières les commerciaux les maîtres
quand on prend dans le temps les les
marion alors c est ce que ça marque une
chercher ici moi je trouvais ça
nouveau vote de gauche émergents on voit
+2 40% d'abstentions chez les moins de
que démocratiquement votre voix ne
qu'il ya une phrase que vous retenez
considèrent le peuple comme le seul
complètement de ton et de gestuelle elle
respectifs laetitia astres jaunards de
difficile de creed ii de trouver une
qu'on veut l'ancien banlieue rouge à la
temporalité propre dans le monde a calé
avec ce débat la phase ultime de sa
intéressant en fait de voir si le
rester sur ce terrain sans aller sur le
fait possible que la guerre en russie
c'est pas un peu pour moi non jean luc
lallaing lots suis d'accord avec
presque toutes les grandes villes
fait aujourd'hui plus figure de show
l'impression que c'était la finale de
certaine rupture c'est odieux
la traditionnelle séance de celles qui
48 millions d'inscrits n'ont pas allumé
aussi exister dans tous les coins oui
souverain contre le bloc qui concède le
compte pas et que les élections ne
d'école les bacheliers mais aussi des
milliards et c'est ce qu'on va justement
très bien en fait plus clairement
françaises dans toutes les grandes
les leçons sur le long terme de ces cinq
la france ce pays qu'on croyait
mélenchon c'est comme boris johnson ce
audiences en fait des débats on a le
ceinture rouge française il a fait des
24 ans mais si vous enlevez les plus de
terrain des grandes idées le problème
consistance à ce concept qui a été
laeticia c'était vraiment le langage
se lève de ces fiches elle se met droite
télévisé que de débats de fond c'est ce
match retour de la coupe du monde le
changeant de cours que les relations
capitales régionales ce qu'on voit pas
parlement ne peut pas regagner un rôle
normalisation de sa banalisation de sa
effectivement on peut dire ça puisque ce
connaître c'est aux éditions perrin et
d'ailleurs qu'en 2017 c'était déjà jean
reflète pas ce que vous voulez donc le
alors les france irréconciliables c'est
débat qui a fait le moins de visibilité
corporel qui était le non verbal qui
leur télé hier soir est ce que vous y
s'en suit une heure et demie de bain de
70 ans au deuxième tour dimanche soir je
c'est qu'on n'avait pas vraiment de
bac + 2 commence à être tiraillé ça
et elle les dom son discours qu'on
pouvoir aux seuls techniciens
années qui se sont écoulées alors une
sont des vieux politique du système qui
qui évoquait d'ailleurs il erre sur
duel d'entre deux tours vous l'avez
scores aussi très importants dans les
mère m'a écouté c'est intéressant que
européennes évoluent en dentelle manière
en bien en ayant une force en étant un
justement dans le résultat de qui arrive
super bowl dévoila de l'entre-deux tours
thiennot lyon les candidats novices et
disais là c'est l'extrême diversité avec
là aussi une expression qu'on emploie
luc mélenchon a good était déjà présent
mobilisée parfois mais qui en fait à une
voyez les cias rejoindra un signe
système institutionnel est vicié c'est
bref le peuple contre l'oligarchie
était frappant ça va pas être simple
débat il ya quand même des choses dans
depuis qu'on a dépeint c'est à dire
notre plateau sonia devillers la
vous lui posiez comme ça parce que je me
évoqué tout à l'heure on enregistre les
information qui vient de nous parvenir
on aille piocher une des phrases qui ne
grandes villes il a même fait des scores
en premier par département même si aussi
foule avec par moment des
connaît sur ce qu'elle pense de la
commence à être du 50-50 dans ces
pour faire les sujets dans cinq ans un
très grande variété donc ça c'est
des gens qui seront des des précaires
professionnels en politique aux presses
supplémentaire de cette lassitude
en 2022 il le présente le vote de la
souvent regardé cette carte qui est
leurs programmes respectifs qui sont
me suis pas sûr que les sondages le
empruntent le masque des populistes ce
pires audiences télévisuelles de tous
disais en quittant le débat hier on
productrice et présentatrice de
on l'évoquait avec carla tri tout à
depuis 1974 dans l'entre-deux tours donc
et c'est vrai que comme l'a dit laeticia
c'est aussi très intéressant et ensuite
campeur quant à moi j'ai d'ailleurs les
vrai contrepoids skins qui ne ce qui
catégories là et c'est aussi le cas je
nous paraît pas saillantes aujourd'hui
etienne lyon c'est intéressant parce que
démocratique française c'est possible
nation
s'est pas complètement étonnant parfois
importants dans des villes relativement
mais des précaires donc périurbain 1
rapport de force très exactement le même
intéressantes ou inquiétantes je pense
interpellations d'habitants de
était dans les tenir ma télévision que
les débats organisés depuis 1974 avec ce
intéressant parce que ces leçons des
universitaires de france et jean-laurent
l'instant élèves sur france inter
de
mais qui le qu'il serait plus tard ça
certain après la la la france insoumise
n'est pas pareil d'accord avec ça ou
vous avez ce fameux vote des périphéries
l' ai dit tout à l'heure des 25-50 25 55
moyenne donc il a un électorat qui est
l'heure notre partenaire ipsos le
pas moi dès les premières minutes la
tout à l'heure vous décriviez la
ça c'est un signe surtout si on a fait
ça prenne une très mauvaise direction
seine-saint-denis épuisé par la
temps je veux dire par là c'est que on
n'est pas ce qui n'est plus et ça n'est
écoutez la gagnerait beaucoup à avoir un
est-ce qu'on classe et jean luc
après il faudrait comparer aux autres
réseaux sociaux s'y sont pas trompés ils
finalement s'il y avait un adjectif que
de la relation glorieuse de son de sa
jeunesse qui est de la génération climat
c'est quand même une grande leçon de
première compagne d'emmanuelle macron
mais qui n'ont aucun pour certains qui
mélenchon parmi les populistes oui je le
cassely la france sous nos yeux économie
sait qu'aujourd'hui le coeur électoral
chiffre 15,6 millions de téléspectateurs
technicité en fait de la séquence
résultats du premier tour par
élections on peut très bien s'intéresser
mais ce qui me gêne dans notre
précarité
l'histoire c'est qu'elle est toujours un
comme vous le dites il avait été
ont une suite des mêmes empilées les
je retiendrai pour ce débat c'est un
donc ça veut dire que moi je veux bien
en effet a fait bien mieux dans les
qui s'était positionné un peu contre les
comme on l'appelle parfois c'est un
qu'on n'arrive pas à désigner un souvent
assez que le composite en fait et qui
notamment chez marine le pen beaucoup de
démocratie c'est que personne
modèle comme au canada comme aux états
tellement monté en épingle on aurait pu
pas une fatalité à la vème république
classerait parmi les populistes mais je
de marine le pen c'est les actifs les 25
peu réécrite donc par les légendes les
jeune est plutôt diplômés sensible la
débat normal et un débat normal ça peut
département et ça nous montre trois
banlieues que qu'elle ne l'a fait dans
seront nationalistes pour certains qui
paysages nouveaux modes de vie cet opus
que l'on dise que tout le monde est
choses qui concerne l'état de droit qui
traverse différents groupes sociaux
certes tu une république présidentielle
s'attendre justement à ce qu'il y ait
captures d'écran de je crois que j'ai vu
c'est deux fois moins que le débat qui
élites et au dos aujourd'hui en tout cas
puissance de son histoire de son destin
de modérer n'essaie de prendre en charge
pouvoir d'achat avec affrontements entre
unis avec des commissions parlementaires
question d'écologie question de
seront islamophobe mais pour d'autres
populiste quoi la droite et l'extrême
s'entendre de deux manières ça peut
cei
50 en gros voilà et les catégories
plus de gens qui veulent s'informer et
d'autres endroits et en particulier
acteurs du présent alors les deux
ne crois pas que pour lui ce soit une
puisque dans le coeur des grandes villes
dans les attaques de marine le pen c'est
france celle où emmanuel macron arrive
et là elle prend elle assume
s'entendre en disant bas il ne s'est
mais elle n'interdit pas que le
avait explosé tous les records en 88
insulte d'ailleurs il me semble qu'il a
passer un même assez drôle sur les cette
finalistes ont repris leur campagne de
féminisme il fait des cartons dans les
qui seront tout à fait différent donc
moi j'habite dans mon appartement
cette france périphérique est ce que
ces demandes pour les transformer pour
rien passé de significatif on n'aura pas
le le candidat de des riches et les
complètement son vocabulaire disons
c'était des cibles faciles et même je
de fait ce n'est pas le cas et oui pour
non je crois qu'il faut être très
populaires et moyennes ce qui pose quand
attitude qui ne faut pas avoir un
françaises et paris en premier lieu mais
c'est une question
pluripartite bombe bipartisane
même parfois revendiquer pour les
attentif avec ça et leur enquête
parlement soit fort et même du temps de
villes puisque vous l'avez dit lille
vétuste qui est très
en faire quelque chose politiquement
terrain ce matin et même accro à saint
en tête en jaune marine le pen est en
national populiste et là elle est allée
françois mitterrand et jacques chirac
à la fameuse petite phrase mitterrand
d'impossibilité parce qu'on ne peut pas
revenir sur la question vous évoquiez
entretien d'embauché avec le maquereau
même des questions sur la suite puisque
on pourrait citer lille on pourrait
montrait que du côté de la politisation
dirais important donc je suis assez déçu
de gaulle le parlement avait plus
simpson je ne sais pas boris johnson il
pour moi c'est ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui et
s'affrontaient alors devant 30 millions
montpellier strasbourg c'est du plus 10
évidemment avec des règles du jeu écrit
d'accord j'ai pas de toilettes j'ai pas
pense que si nous commentateurs experts
citer lyon où ils arrivent eux aussi en
tout à l'heure il me semble que c'est
réconcilier de discours comme je
d'importance donc là on a vraiment connu
qui demande ou giscard qui demande à
croisant les bras
denis sur le thème du logement marine le
on est à 50 50 à peu près donc c'est
élites oui alors en tout cas c'est sûr
personne n'en sort je disais que c'était
bleu et jean luc mélenchon et en rouge
ces gens sont amenés à vieillir et à la
une brique de plus dans l'explication de
meilleur est en effet là elle fait autre
tête strasbourg se sont à chaque fois
de valider écrite validé rediscutée tous
de téléspectateurs et si on se penche
pression vous le souhaitez est-ce que
est quand même issu d'un vieux parti et
entre guillemets de la politique on on
de sac à main j'ai pas honte de le dire
points par rapport à 2010 est et il est
regardant ailleurs donc c'est ça que les
c'était une bataille de chiffres une
que emmanuel macron lui a mené une
le symptôme de et bien sûr nous mais on
une régression sur ce point là
mitterrand le prix du marquis mitterrand
pen dans la somme notamment pour
parce que près le propriétaire veut rien
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus de divers
sur l'évolution qu'on découvre à
campagne tout à fait différente cette
s'ennuie on lâche c'est qu'en pensent
chose que du techno mais si en face vous
c'est aussi des questions
jean luc mélenchon aussi un oui mais il
donc là on a vraiment la région
bataille de réformes je ne sais pas si
qui le fait traîne et qui finalement lui
remplacer progressivement le corps
en quasi monopole dans les banlieues et
gens ont vu ils ont vu deux
rencontrer des chauffeurs routiers hugo
est bien tous les moyens de venir nous
organisationnelles c'est à dire que
cette on dit fatigue désarroi
fois-ci de la fois précédente 1 il n'a
est clivée en fait ce qui peut expliquer
l'antenne de ses audiences on observe
donne le prix le monopole du coeur etc
tout le monde comprenait ces débats
c'est difficile en fait d'être au four
a un instinct il n'a pas fait de
parisienne alors vous ne voyez pas à
n'avez rien vous n'avez pas de discours
électoral le plus le plus âgé qui a
pas appelé un renouvellement ce qui est
lemonnier
qu'elle s'érode d'année en année en 2007
ça fait vingt ans dans l'assurance
pourquoi le mouvement n'a pas continué
ruptures sert qu'en fait le parti il
démocratique qu'on voit à l'heure
entre la tva versus le bouclier enfin je
et au moulin d'avoir un parti surtout
par ailleurs assez normal eco aurait été
cause du bandeau mais aussi les
à la même hauteur en fait ça tombe un
sociale qu'on se pose la question de ce
mais par contre par contre on aura aussi
encore un rempart contre le front
actuelle qu'on voit sur l'abstention
affections des voies les outre-mer il
manque dans cette coalition c'est le
faut quand même se rendre compte que le
suicidaire appelé à faire le grand
qu'est ce que c'est que le populisme et
quand on n'a pas voulu le construire
aussi mais les banlieues n'ont jamais
avant-dernier déplacent moins pour
le débat de entre nicolas sarkozy et
un débat normal au sens où on aura un
petit peu à plat il ne se passe rien ce
national je le que le rassemblement
même un petit peu plus en fait et qu'on
parti conservateur anglais il a deux
je je je je me demandais et je le
comme parti qui va s'implanter
alors elle a été moins forte cette fois
vote populaire des périphériques voilà
manifesté avec tes gilet jaune alors
verra des ses désirs et des séminaires
marine le pen qui tente un retour
ségolène royal enregistré 20 millions de
national je le dis parce que parfois les
cents ans et ça qui fait un fabuleux
qu'a fait emmanuel macron lui de son
ménage au centre du dégagisme bien sûr
qui reste la chasse gardée de marine le
ci un quelconque on l'attendait au
de réflexion pour savoir en fait est ce
regrette juste quand on regarde aussi
localement dans des endroits qui ne sont
aussi pour des raisons d'éloignement et
débat entre deux candidats qui sont
gens associent marine le pen ou le rn à
notre démocratie c'est que il ne change
téléspectateurs en 2012 17 17 17
pen et c'est un jeu c'est à la fois un
que c'est un terme utile ou pas est-ce
considérés et qui se sont posés l'un
pas complètement non plus acquis à cette
les chiffres d'audience ya peut-être un
je pense que ce n'était pas la bonne
côté c'est que il a alterné techno avec
premier tour mais elle a quand même
géographique 1 mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas c'est toujours le même parti alors
politique à mener mais il est certain
que c'est un terme qui peut être défini
était plus forte que d'habitude et puis
comme l'autre comme des adversaires
petit mea culpa à faire nos journalistes
cause là et ça évidemment après ça a des
une question qui est annoncée qui est
choix stratégique que la france est
un vote réac donc de personnes âgées en
il ya différentes façons de le diriger
respectable et respecté l'un de l'autre
ou pas vous avez mentionné le fait que
que en effet cette fois ci il est le
surtout en fait l'abstention gagne du
millions pour le duel entre françois
des raisonnements intellectuelle à ses
très débattue depuis les gilet jaune
soumise à fait elle cartonne en fait
c'est un terme mince au sens où en fait
je suis bien d'accord avec vous et voilà
comme des personnes qui peuvent avoir
il y avait une crise médiatique c'est à
effets très fort parce qu'on sait en
hollande et nicolas sarkozy et en 2017
pourquoi n'y a pas eu de jonction entre
candidat y compris dans les votes des
fait c'est plutôt l'inversé voilà alors
une discussion et je trouve que c'est
sociologie électorale que il ya des
il est très flexible il peut se passer
dire qu'on a monté ce débat comme étant
terrain élection après élection et là je
je ferai une distinction parce qu'il est
d'une idéologie à l'autre il veut
les catégories populaires de banlieue et
fins assez subtil est assez intéressant
16,4 millions pour déjà emmanuel macron
on analyse ce vote on analyse les les
très intéressant justement dans la
classes qui sont les classes les plus
effets de contexte il ya des effets
quand même soutenu par des députés qui
pas très bon pour faire des prévisions
vraiment la pierre angulaire de cette
s'accrocher à la gauche comme à la
parce qu'il lui disait mais vous dites
aisées un c on l'a vu il a été fait la
celle de la périphérie bon il y aurait
socio démographique on parlait des
perspective qui est celle de marine le
fractures françaises avec cette question
droite les définitions
ça et vous vous contredisez par exemple
et marine le pen néanmoins on peut
politique mais enfin il me semble que le
plein de d'explication ça mais juste le
sont les conservateurs qui sont les
différentes variables ici de vote mais
pen parce qu'elle arrive à se poser
vous voulez baisser la tva sur l'énergie
ça se rejoint ou autour du du populisme
campagne tout allait basculer on l'a
apporter cette nuance ce débat
demande y est c'est plutôt la france qui
comme une candidate légitime qui peut
à hégémonique mai 2011 qu'on retient
fait que marine le pen soit les voir des
premier et le second tour des
mêmes sur le modèle anglais mais
va bien la france qui est je pense que
législatives seront sûrement marqué par
fossile mais en même temps vous voulez
interagir dans ce qui est quand même le
il ya des effets contextuel c'est à dire
présidentiel n'est aujourd'hui plus
routiers dans un resto routier franck
laetitia vous ai trouvé que la
lutter contre le réchauffement
une abstention beaucoup plus forte donc
que vous allez aussi voté en fonction de
c'est trois points en général c'est la
prestation de marine le pen hier soir
seulement suivi uniquement à la
climatique c'est contradictoire et il
emmanuel macron était en seine saint
je n'en cas c'est lille qui a une vision
moment de la discussion forte d'une
ça c'est toute une série d'éléments
était l'illustration d'une candidature
denis et répond aussi un peu à vos
personnalisation du pouvoir la mise à
télévision hier et pour la première fois
de l'europe qui croit en son avenir
ce que font votre famille bien sûr mais
fallait avoir suivi toute la discussion
qu'on pourrait en citer beaucoup
distance des corps intermédiaires et le
d'autres hein on y reviendra peut-être
questions simplement sur les gilles et
élection présidentielle qui est quand
il est aidé également diffusées et
grâce à l'europe enfin c'est tout ça la
pour comprendre ce qu'il voulait dire il
populiste pour voir et je défends ce
vos voisins vos proches les gens autour
tout à l'heure mais qui à mon avis
rejet des élites et donc de ce point de
même le sceptre de la vème république et
france et les retraités quoi et le lait
je ne sais pas si à quels autres travaux
est très bon là dedans parce que c'est
attestent de cette de cette fatigue oui
de vous et ça dans les petits villages
thème que la doxa ambiante tente de
commentées sur quatre chaînes de la
vue là et la demande qu'on les mette à
quelqu'un qui va vite qui est
ça joue énormément parce qu'il ya un
faisait allusion mais je me rappelle qu
les routes des retraités et d'une grande
donc de ce point de vue là je suis
parce que on on va vraiment débattre
plateforme switch salle du journaliste
entièrement d'accord avec vous ce débat
banaliser de minorer d'éjecter du débat
entre soi et donc il ya une espèce
partie des retraités en effet non mais
ayant
intelligent et donc là le débat prenez
la porte et de ce point de vue là en
des recherches très intéressante
à participer de cette normalisation
fait moi ce qui m'avait beaucoup frappé
je jean-laurent cassely et je trouvais
samuel etienne que vous découvrez à
d'évidence qui va se produire sur le nom
est-ce qu'il ya quand même une phrase
public le populisme ça veut dire quelque
un petit peu forme mais ça retomber
chercheurs de grenoble et qu'ils ont
ça très intéressant aussi est
moins dans cette élection si que dans
l'antenne mais aussi du godet crypte de
que vous retiendrez pour l'histoire à
aussitôt parce qu' elle ne suivait pas
complexifiée dont ceux justement cette
chose thomas est en ce moment dans nos
d'un ou de quelques candidats mais est
l'élection précédente c'est que si vous
vision en fait en montrant qu' il
part du gharb ajax ou volé à part gérard
jean mathia et de sardasht et streamer
non plus donc j'avais l'impression en
prenez ces trois critères là d'une
ce que c'est une occasion manquée de la
fait qu'ils ne se parlaient pas ça log
qui ont d'ailleurs dû débourser 1500
fallait être un petit peu plus un petit
certaine manière emmanuel macron était
démocraties
part de jean luc mélenchon qui aurait pu
un peu fatigué
peu plus nuancé en fait sur ces blocs là
quelqu'un qui faisait ça rejet des
euros pour réutiliser images de tf1 et
mais que oui en effet c'est c'est le
occidental on le voit monter partout
candidat qui chercha afin qu'ils
d'ailleurs c'est souvent les populistes
qui disent eux mêmes ça n'existe pas
quittent pas qui parle un électorat
c'est un terme tiroirs passez votre
riches après la position de marine le
chemin et hier marine le pen s'est
pen ici c'est de faire exister des blocs
et ça c'est ce que font tous les
inscrite dans cette lignée trump ball
candidats à une élection présidentielle
sonar aux mêmes or ban avec un passage
ou même tous les politiques le but d'un
responsable politique c'est doc
d'imposer une certaine grille de lecture
moi j'ai retenu un passage que je n'ai
du monde la classe ouvrière contre les
pas vu après aujourd'hui dans la presse
autres les élites contre le peuple je
ni ni dans les médias audiovisuels ce
passage qui vraiment c'est tout le tout
la quintessence du discours populiste
écoutez
le bon sens d' empêcher de nuire les
prédateurs d'en haut 1 ceux qui pillent
nos fleurons nationaux et qui font de
l'optimisation fiscale et puis les
prédateurs d'en bas c'est à dire les
délinquants et les criminels qui
harcèlent les braves gens et qu'il faut
bien dire pourrisseurs existence voilà
c'est typique voilà c'est la mâchoire
populiste c'est à dire qui est la
défiance envers les élites les
prédateurs d'en haut et il y a cette
haine envers les prédateurs d'en bas les
délinquants elle ne dit pas immigrés
mais parce qu'elle est en train de se
normaliser mais tout le monde l'entend
et cette mâchoire populiste elle avait
hier marine le pen bien en bouche alors
c'est quoi le peuple russe qu'au peuple
définisse c'est une idéologie mince
simpliste qui qui tend à se revendiquer
de l'incarnation du peuple on l'a senti
hier marine le pen souffrait beaucoup
elle souffrait avec les jeunes elle
souffrait avec les pauvres elle
souffrait avec les opprimés avec les
victimes et donc on se pose en
incarnation du peuple pour prendre le
pouvoir et ensuite installé en démontant
un peu les institutions démocratiques
un pouvoir autoritaire avec des médias
muselés et avec parfois est très souvent
quand on regarde par exemple la hongrie
durban - de liberté que celle promise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]